what's going on man how are you I'm good
man it's nice to be in New York it's
nice to be back here yeah I feel like
I'm you know coming to somewhere
familiar do you guys like those
streaming services now it's like if you
do a movie you could it could be in the
theater or there's like so many other
places for it to come out you must kind
of like the extra options yeah I guess
it's um it's an interesting time
everything's really changing you know
and and before obviously a movie was
something you saw in the theater and no
that's not necessarily the case but um I
think this will get a a slight release
I've had a slight release of you
well yeah they put it out in theaters
like limited or whatever right yeah so
they didn't qualify considered for
awards and stuff like that does it like
did you like do you still have the
premieres and all that stuff or have
those those kind of gone away when
something like this happens yeah I mean
this this is getting a Premiere I'm
gonna be on holiday so I'm gonna miss it
but yeah it's because it's a big thing
it's the first animation from sky dance
animation it's the first kind of Apple
TV plus exclusive movie so um animation
so it's uh yeah it's getting a bit of a
Fanfare which is nice not that I'll be
there I'll be on a beach in Greece oh
yeah
you're pretty good because you had at
flying under the radar I don't think
people like associate you with the fact
that like you're part of multiple
franchises like you're a franchise guy
I'm a franchise hole Yeah I'm not
meaning to be you know it just kind of
happened I mean it's a pretty sweet gig
where you're like okay I mean I guess
they're gonna need me to do this and
they're gonna need it isn't you know you
kind of you you you sign up for stuff
and then like with Mission Impossible
we've been shooting that since September
2020 and obviously the pandemics had a
big effect on the shoot but we've been
soldiering on and it's gonna be amazing
and we've finished the first we're doing
two back to work oh wow so now I'm on
number eight until like October next
year so that you're kind of stuck with
it you know right and as fun as it
sounds it can get a little tedious
and uh were you that were you there with
all those coveted protocols and stuff
like that they had to stop a couple of
times right yeah we had we had a couple
of shutdowns you know it just was
inevitable at the beginning but um we
kind of invented the whole the whole
covered protocol right right yeah yeah
and um and we did okay it's it's you
know I mean it's a pain in the ass but
we we managed it yeah people got mad at
Tom Cruise but it was like you're trying
to keep a production going it's like
well that was interesting because they
released that audio I think as a kind of
a you know like a [ __ ] you to Tom and
then it actually everyone was going no
fair enough he was sort of standing up
for the people he's employing and you
know he had a he had a big old shout but
basically what he was saying was correct
you know yeah it was an interesting one
it's wild though I saw the thing that
you put on your Instagram about like
that man I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
tell you about Tom Cruise anymore
because it because I because I read the
I read the headline right that was like
Simon Pegg is out here and he's giving
Tom Cruise big secrets away and then I
read the quotes and I'm like this is
like an anecdote this is a funny story
because everybody wants to be the
authority on him and because he doesn't
engage anyone who gets close to him they
want stuff from so you say the slightest
thing some story and you think oh they
want to know about work and you tell but
no no it's a story that they want to put
it's a it's a click bait story yeah they
can put his name in the title
everything's mad at the moment because
the Top Gun being so huge so you know
yeah what is it like when he's on the
set because I've never met him but I
imagine they said even in Hollywood
there's like levels of of like celebrity
and he said like when Jack Nicholson was
on the set for um A Few Good Men
everybody kind of felt it like you know
what I mean him and everybody else
because it was Jack Nicholson I guess
that's kind of how it is with him well
he's he's a real sort of team player on
when it comes to the to the filmmaking
process so you know he he knows
everyone's name and it's not like oh
[ __ ] here he comes you know he's kind of
just here he is you know we all get
ready to work when he's there because
you know it's uh he gives a 100 and
expects us to so we all like put our
cigarettes out and stuff up getting off
with each other and start working who
are you playing me yeah in Mission yes I
play a character called Benji Dunn who's
like a kind of
human Sat Nav
what I do is give him uh directions okay
and reveal aspects of the plot to the
audience so it's a good part it's great
yeah I've been doing it since like
number three which is 2006. so I've been
on these movies for like 16 years and um
I should probably see them honestly yeah
I did see what part are you playing I
was like what I remember I I believe the
same one
I did see uh the one where he was on the
Burj Khalifa yeah so I'm afraid of
heights so that was [ __ ] terrifying
well you should see the the the
following films five six uh were
directed by Chris Macquarie and I mean
you know I know I'm in these and I'm
biased but these films kind of defy the
law of diminishing returns they get
better right and worse and that's a
pretty rare thing to be able to do I
think yeah yeah do you so do you is it
more pressure to be a part of one of
those kind of you know billion dollar
franchise movies or to be doing
something where it's all you like you
you know when when you're the writer
co-writer co-director like when you're
when this is your baby and you're kind
of responsible or when you're a piece of
this giant thing that people are
depending on you much more stressful
like when me and Edgar released the film
that's right that's all on us you know
right whereas with Mission you can if
it's not very good you can just not that
it ever isn't very good it seems to be
great are they gonna fall on your
shoulders yeah yeah I can just sort of
disown it straight away wash my hands no
sorry but with the other stuff were you
on set when he was running down the face
of the uh of the building yeah holy [ __ ]
the fact the insurance I can't stop
thinking how do they allow what do you
have to go through to get the biggest
star in Hollywood to run down that that
face I lost that a lot and I honestly
don't know I think maybe he underwrites
it or something like he broke his ankle
on the last one yeah and that was the
first time he'd kind of injured himself
and obviously lost his no claims bonus
on his insurance policy but um you know
we had to the weird thing was is that
he's running along he jumps these two
Bill he jumps between these buildings it
hits the wall
and he put his leg out to steady himself
which wasn't in the kind of like the the
list of things he had to do to do the
stunt and the minute he kind of deviated
broke his ankle and you see it in the
film he gets up and he limps out of shot
and that was him being a producer not an
actor that was him knowing if he didn't
clear the shot it was going to cost the
production millions and millions of
dollars so he limps out on a shattered
liquid ankle I guess that by the way
this this answers the original question
which was like what's easier when you
don't have to worry about how you ensure
no your stars running down buildings
it's probably easier to knock no my
brother yeah why would it have cost
millions of dollars because they
wouldn't have had any of this shot or
because they would have had to go back
and reshoot the scene again and the the
logistics of not completing that moment
would have just caused a huge headache
oh okay so he managed to kind of you
know and then he just collapsed and
and then the doctor told him he wasn't
he was part he could possibly never run
again
and then really yeah he said you
wouldn't you probably would walk for
nine months you won't Sprint perhaps
ever nine weeks later
it's sprinting across the top of the
bridge in London so what do you do when
that happens I guess do you pick up and
shoot other scenes around or do you just
go home for a month and a half yeah we
had to shut down for a little while and
uh do what we could without him but yeah
we got around it and um
you know that was an insurance claim I
guess and
but these things happen I mean yeah it's
amazing that it was something as
innocuous as a broken ankle yeah
especially and one of them was like on
the side of a plane yeah and he rode off
a cliff on a motorbike in seven like I
mean of course why wouldn't you yeah if
you watch the trailer they actually put
it in the trailer because part I think
the the appeal of these movers is that
the stunts are real that's the kind of
Mantra yeah and at the end of the
trailer you see rides off a cliff on a
motorbike drops the motorbike and then
just falls out of shot and then
obviously opened a parachute at some
point yeah yeah that would be Jackie
Chan so popular two people left exactly
did his own stunts that really is the
selling point yeah he's absolutely the
best of that when you uh started doing
stuff with Star Wars were you like
hey you guys know I'm in Star Trek too
I don't know if I'm allowed to cross the
street yeah can I cross streams here
well it was JJ Abrams who was doing it
he kind of like because I was a bit when
I found out that JJ was doing Star Wars
yeah I remember I was watching a I got
the an email out I felt kind of jealous
you know I was like oh Dad's leaving us
for the other kids you know because we
he directed Star Trek of course yeah
yeah yeah and it's like all right he's
gonna [ __ ] off to Star Wars now is he
that's nice but then we had dinner and
he said oh do you want to come and play
a blobfish and I was like sure yeah yeah
all the kind of jealousy or whatever
goes away you're like yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah those guys the first time
I saw Star Trek I thought it was
terrible but then I realized I was on a
bootleg copy I was in somebody's house
and they had a bully someone like these
camera angles are so bad like they're
zooming in on the [ __ ] legs I'm like
what are they doing and then I found out
like a year later I'd watch the bootleg
copy and I saw it again I was filming it
with the cameras that was exactly
it just didn't make sense how poorly it
was shot you didn't realize that that's
hilarious no I didn't it was my friend
who had a projection screen in his house
I thought he was above that was wrong
I do love the idea of putting a bootleg
on a projection screen dude I was
Furious when I found out that I was
wasted two hours watching him
I love it
um Star Trek's continuing right are they
gonna I think so I mean as far as I know
that that planning a fourth one I don't
know when that's gonna happen that that
depends on everyone's availability
obviously syncing up and also I mean I'm
on Mission until next year late next
year I don't know when we'll do it but
apparently while late next year they're
shooting yeah it looks sounds like it
yeah it's gonna be nice to know you have
it like you're always going to work but
just to know like to know exactly what
you're doing for the next year the one
thing that is frustrating is that I've
got a lot of things I want to do and and
you know I mean I grow when I write a
new film together and there's a
possibility doing some theater yeah
there's this and that and and you kind
of like your dance card is just booked
out so you're a bit stuck oh you like to
in theater I'm gonna do some yeah have
you not for a long long time but some
has come up and I kind of want to do it
seems difficult theater compared to I
mean regular acting is hard but theater
just seems like so there's just no room
to redo it yeah you stand up you can
kind of Riff it and and work your way
back to your your material but with a
play if you forget the line yes and like
if I if I [ __ ] up a joke right but it
happens all the time and you just
address it you make fun of it you move
forward but I'm always like watching
guys like what do you do if you forget
like do the other actors actually will
pick you up what do you do if you just
blank yeah I mean I know it's such an
amateur question but it's what terrifies
me about these are like phones going off
now it's still a problem people never
Peter O'Toole told a really funny story
about when he played Hamlet
and there was a bit in in the in this in
this in the you know one of the famous
soliloquists when he runs down right to
the front of the stage Vengeance I
listened to this huge fluores and he got
to the bottom of the stage and some guy
in the front row just went
Peter O'Toole went oh piss off
just dropped carrots
[Laughter]
my favorite Peter O'Toole thing was
Caligula did you ever see Caligula oh
that's a mad film isn't it and he played
uh Tiberius which is such an odd movie
to get like guys like him Malcolm
McDowell and uh they didn't know like a
lot of the actors didn't know what was
going on like yeah none real actors
would go home and they'd be like okay
now let's do it okay get naked yeah and
uh oh my God uh Helen Mirren tremendous
cat she was very sexy but it still is
yeah yeah lovely yeah are you does it
like uh she's got it
we can save it we can save it with that
does it blow your mind that like uh
like you've you've done so many films
and so many giant films and and you've
you've written and you've read you've
done everything since then but still to
this day I'm sure
all the time people just bring up Sean
of the Dead still oh yeah and I'm happy
about that yeah I would have to imagine
yeah it's it was all kind of Debut
really and it's certainly our debut over
here in the states that was how we um
you know we arrived here which is a nice
way to arrive but I can't imagine that
when you were making it you were like
this is the one that lasts forever no we
didn't even know if it would be anyone
would see it you know what I mean we
thought it might be on we might get it
on DVD maybe yeah and it might be on at
the cinema for a week in in the UK we
never knew it would come over here but
yeah I still get asked it people are
still you're gonna do a show in the dead
too no
I think sometimes people don't know what
else to say about something so they just
ask like is that coming back yeah no
it's not yeah I know people want the
same thing again and again that's the
thing is it I mean the cinema kind of
cases the urge now because we do just
see the same thing again and again what
are you a fan of now because I feel like
all you're like you're a part of so much
fan culture but you do it like it's
become your professional yeah yeah like
is there anything that you're like this
is what I geek out over I watch a lot of
Korean television at the moment and the
reason is is because my daughter is a
mad sort of K-pop fan and she loves sort
of Korean culture we watch a lot of
there's a lot of K dramas on on Netflix
and they're really great there's some
not just squid game we were kind of you
know into it before squid game happened
but um yeah we sort of geek out over
because I don't know there's a weird
tonal difference with their dramas
sometimes they can be like we watch this
one called Vincenzo
and it was like this this Korean guy who
had been a mafia conciliary in Italy
comes back to to Seoul and he saves this
little community of people but it was
like it would be really funny and
horribly violent then really upsetting
and then really moving and it there's no
type of relationship
yeah like nocturnal consistency
but so that
um I'm really enjoying the boys at the
moment and as is that a superhero movie
no I should be serious yeah yeah Matt
Sarah always talks about that yeah yeah
it's really popular it's on Amazon yeah
I when the comic came out the guy that
Drew it designed one of the characters
Huey as me and so I kind of had this
bizarre kind of guest role in a comic
that I you know someone told me about it
and then I wrote to the guy and said oh
this is cool thanks man then DC who
published it at the time before they
dropped it because it's too [ __ ] out
there you know it's really extreme as is
the show
um wrote To Me begged me not to sue them
this is nice anyway so when they did the
TV show Jack Quade plays Huey in the TV
show but they invited me to play his dad
as a kind of you know oh that's great a
little nod to the comic so um so but
despite being in it it's you'd love it
man it's so outrageous it it goes places
you would never expect I heard nothing
but good things about it yeah I'm not
big on superhero culture at all but this
show I'm aware of because everybody is
it's sort of a takedown of it all you
know it's kind of it's it it's a very
timely takedown of the whole superhero
Thing suggesting that if they really did
exist they'd be [ __ ]
by the way how does the leather go when
they're asking you not to sue them
that's a pretty ballsy thing for a a
studio not so many words it was like hey
Simon would you mind signing this uh
waiver for your likeness rights and uh
just because yeah just kind of some
lawyer just really if we say it like
this he'll never know that we kind of
ripped him off were you hesitant or are
you like ah I didn't care it was kind of
fun you know I felt like pretty
flattered that this guy had given me a
kind of role in a comment yeah I was big
into Comics at the time so it was like
it felt great I'm sure there are people
though that would be like oh this is
really flattering this is really cool I
can sue for this guy yeah I remember on
the set of Star Trek Into Darkness we're
working with Peter Weller and there's a
Great British sort of hip-hop track from
the from 1990 called Silver uh called 20
seconds to comply it's by Silver Bullet
we used it in the World's End in the
fight scene in the world's end and it's
got loads of samples from RoboCop I was
like hey Pete listen to this it's great
it's got your voice in it and stuff he
was like I'm gonna show those [ __ ]
it's cool you know Peter Weller was my
professor at Syracuse he taught the
Roman Empire through film yeah that's
right yeah yeah he's a he's a he's a a
really interesting guy he's incredible
he's like so obsessed with the Roman
Empire and everything through film that
the idea it was like a three-hour
lecture but you were supposed to watch a
movie and then like in lecture and then
he would we would kind of discuss it as
a class after he would spend the entire
three-hour lecture talking yeah and then
you know what I mean like he'd spend the
entire time talking and go like oh you
guys are gonna have to watch the movie
like during like during the week we'll
come back next week and discuss it but
it would be like yeah what's a great
Roman movie what would he consider a
great movie about Rome Ben Hur probably
or yeah El Cid something like that I
mean we watched every Jesus Christ
Superstar was on the on the list of
movies that we watched anything that was
even remotely tied right yeah the Life
of Brian
that's probably you want that baby
very funny film
um yeah the uh the best I can't really
watch Shakespeare
watching Brando do Shakespeare was
always good I don't know how like uh
like real Shakespearean actors feel
about that but him I could watch do it
for some reason to film yeah enjoyable
Shakespeare is weird because you watch
it and you don't have any kind of
immediate understanding of what's being
said but you somehow managed to buy
osmosis understand what's going on yeah
it can be you know I saw Ian McKellen do
King Lear and that was amazing and then
I saw him do Hamlet recently they did an
age-blind Hamlet so he played Hamlet
he's 85 and when Hamlet's older than his
mum and dad the whole sort of edible
thing goes out the window
it was a bit straight yeah this seems
far more appropriate than I remember it
being
um who do you think uh who have you
found has the hardest fans
to please when you're like jumping into
the franchises between Doctor Who yeah
Star Trek Star Wars I mean these are
people who who take these licenses very
very seriously to be honest and as
someone who kind of was you know kicked
off about the prequels in the uh and
when they came out
the Star Wars fan base really seems to
be the most kind of toxic at the moment
I'm really very controversial to say
that
I mean I'm out of it now I'm not I don't
sort of I've apologized for the things I
said about you know Jar Jar Binks
because of course there was a [ __ ]
actor involved yeah and he was getting a
lot of flack and it wasn't a you know a
camp rabbit it was a human being right
and and because it got a lot of hate he
he suffered you know and I feel terrible
about being part of that you know in
space in a comedy show my character was
always ragging on those films but really
that was just me talking about how much
I didn't like them but like I found the
Star Trek fans have always been very
very inclusive you know Star Trek's
about diversity it has been since
1966 it always was there's no sort of
like oh you're suddenly being woke now
Star Wars Star Trek was woke from the
beginning you know yeah we had a
Japanese uh navigator at a just after
the second world war you know there was
a black woman on the deck in a position
of authority this is massively
Progressive Star Wars suddenly there's
there's a little bit more diversity and
everyone's kicking off about it and it's
it's really sad you know yeah wow you
know what's not sad is this movie luck
the new movie comes out August 5th
exclusively on Apple TV plus I'm excited
because I'm always looking for new
animated movies to show my kids because
they will go through them that's great
it's such a lovely movie it's really I
play a lucky cat and uh it's all takes
place in this weird world of where Lux
generated and it's it's one of those
films that
you can watch it with your kids and
you'll get something from it too you
know and I'll tell you that Apple TV
plus uh with their live action they've
they won best picture so no pressure
yeah no pressure
well thank you you're great uh come back
soon and uh we'll be right back stay
there